okay
the time has come
[Music]
so rrr is Indian Cinema tollywood not
Bollywood that I've gotten a lot of
requests to review but in that I can't
help but feel the expectation for this
review and I can only feel like I'm
going to disappoint people because I
don't know what I can bring to the
conversation that hasn't already been
said but if you're curious as to my
opinion on RR well here we go so rrr is
directed by director SS Raja muli and
essentially what they've done took a
couple of historical revolutionary
figures from India they were like let's
put them in a movie and make them action
heroes so the setup of the film it takes
place in the early 20th century India is
under British occupation Ray Stevenson
plays big British dick I guess we'll
call them that and there's a little girl
and they're like oh she sings so well
we'll just take her we'll kidnap her
without a second thought so beam is like
I'll get her back that's his quest he's
going to find this girl who's been
kidnapped then on the other side of
things and this is a big hook it's just
very compelling for me Raju right when
meeting him you are immediate we met
with that feeling of why are you in the
military of the British colonial
oppressors how why this is very
compelling for me also I guess he's the
biggest badass in the country because in
a scene where is him versus everybody in
an absurdly entertaining hook that is
just going to draw you in so Raju is
looking for Beam Beam is looking for
this girl and then these two guys become
friends best friends and as much as
we're going to talk about the action I
will get there that's the core of the
story it is a film about friendship
again with the great hooks that just
draw me in it's like this movie was
crafting ways like how do we get to
Jeremy's brain
yeah this is good two guys who are
friends on opposite sides of this fight
they don't know it there's so many close
calls to where they're going to find out
but they don't the Friendship of these
two guys is the core of the film just
waiting for it to explode you're waiting
for it to just blow up metaphorically
speaking that is and Raju is a good
friend you know they have their dance
off and he just acts like he blows out
his knee to help his friend look like he
won the dance contest because he's
trying to impress a girl dude is a good
friend because we all did it we all know
what that's like we all purposely missed
the shot in Mass Effect 3 we were
shooting with Garris we know what a good
friend is and that dude's a good friend
and for my part I didn't know anything
about the people these two characters
are based off of so I didn't know where
this was going and I'm not even going to
tell you where it's going because that
was a huge part of the Intrigue for me
and I suppose there's gonna be two sides
of the entertainment Spectrum on this
one one side's gonna be like oh I can't
wait to see where this is going because
I know where it's going it's gonna be
people like me like I don't know and
that's why I'm hooked so the action
sequences how are they they are
literally everything I can think my
teeth into they're entertaining they're
over the top funny enough the CGI
animals there's this disclaimer that
comes out at the beginning it's like we
didn't use any real animals they are CGI
it was like oh we know I mean you can
tell the animals in this movie I've seen
better CGI out there but the spirit of
the film is alive my friends I don't
care that there was an entire CGI zoo
that was brought into a fight I just
love the fact that they were all brought
into the fight he really shows you it's
like people always gripe about oh CGI
you can notice CGI what they mean is the
spirit of the film is dull as [ __ ]
because if the spirit of the film is
alive you can forgive bad CGI it's my
experience anyway and it's not just that
the her bow and arrow fights dude swings
a motorcycle around as a weapon at one
point but the fights in the
cinematography they were clean you could
see what was happening that above all
else I appreciate if you're going to
give me an action movie at least frame
it up to where I can see it which is
kind of a wild thought take historical
figures from history that deals with
very heavy content and make them action
heroes but without compromising any of
the seriousness and weight of the
subject matter they're still
heart-wrenching subject matter it's not
lost because like oh it's action stake
one same with the dance sequences and
musical sequences I've heard people say
they felt out of play I didn't feel a
lot of plays for me they felt within
context like the dance sequence I
already mentioned it was a fun energetic
way of showing the character
relationships showing them Advance Raju
and beam's friendship plus stuff you
British guys like this is disgusting
she's like yeah well they're fun and
you're not later dick I thought it was a
creatively entertaining way of having
our two main shoot classism in the face
there's also a scene that's a very heavy
scene in which case now it's a musical
scene dude starts singing that didn't
feel out of place for me either it felt
within context I've seen many movies and
or animations that had musical sequences
among a heavy scene using music to evoke
emotion that's it's a time-honored
tradition amongst Cinema so it all felt
within context for me it is
craftsmanship to have an action film
that has absurd over-the-top action
spectacle dance sequences musical
sequences but none of it takes away from
the gravity of the situation and the
tragedies that happen in situations like
this also the action being over the top
was it cheesy over the top as with all
things depends on how you look at
suppose you could say it's cheesy over
the top but for me it came across as fun
the kind of fun that Hollywood used to
know how to have it was refreshing in
that sense RR is like the movie within a
movie in a Tarantino film only it's
actually a movie in our world I saw a
quote you know those Sizzle quotes that
reviewers and critics give and they'll
be like that's a good one bam it's right
there something along the lines of this
is the movie that should make Hollywood
nervous I agree and again with RR
becoming as big as it's become Hollywood
will try to capture that lightning in a
bottle in the most sterile boring and
manufactured way possible and I promise
you it's not gonna feel the same so yes
rrr should make Hollywood nervous also
cherry on top cannot go without
addressing this this film is three hours
long and it's probably
I'm gonna say one of the best because I
don't want to say the best and then
after this video is up like ah this
other one did they did do it well
shouldn't have said the best so I keep
it vague and pull it back by saying one
of the best but this is one of the best
uses of time management in a movie I've
ever seen three hours long never felt
like three hours long the movie always
had momentum it was always being pushed
forward they made the most of their time
I've seen 90 minute movies that drag on
Far More Than This three hour film this
movie I don't think is going to be for
everybody in Western audiences some
people might find tonal conflict some
people might find the action sequences
over the top in that cheesy way rather
than a fun or fulfilling way but for Me
Not only was the movie fun Not only was
it fulfilling but it was memorable I'm
going to remember RR and if I'm being
honest movies like this are why I came
up with the term awesome tacular because
sometimes awesome and spectacular just
they're not enough on their own you got
to combine them I thought RR was awesome
tacular
[Music]
had a lot of fans suggesting this when
I'm flipping it now thank you for
clicking on my face putting it at the
end of the video seriously I appreciate
all of you thank you for watching thank
you for recommending I watch RR so rrr
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]